did it on course to win with the black
pieces meaning nepo if he wants to stay
in the World Cup has to win with black
in the next 10 minute game look at that
nepo cursing there I think
nepo clearly not happy with the way
things are going
Yan trying to create some drawing
chances I mean
what fit it needs to do is get his King
like to B2 I would not exchange pawns
here I think this is a great move
because you don't want to allow white
the possibility of checking your king
when it starts to travel I just feel
this is the right move to play for a win
keep the pawns on the books this Rook
has to permanently stay behind the a
pawn it can never get active because the
black Rook wants to move away and queen
and as soon as a black Rook moves away
white needs to be able to take that pawn
so can visit now get his King into the
position white can't come forwards gives
us a check and Report Queens so the
white King has to remain fairly passive
and that would allow Black's King to
come in and the winning idea again
try and get the king here but it's not
as simple as the evaluation bar might
think the evaluation bar is saying this
is completely winning
no I was going to say and here you know
be very careful with where he puts the
king you can't put it to E2 because you
have like tricky moves like E3 on the
board and that's why he plays King to G2
and for video it's all about activating
the king and as you mentioned that
whites were completely tied down has to
always guard up 1802 it's game over
Simon all black has to do is just walk
the king over to B2 completely winning
there's nothing white can do nepo's king
is just trapped
can't move the king anywhere because
Village play has been exceptional he's
paralyzing the king for moving forwards
the king can't come forwards because of
a check and as Ivanka said the simple
winning plan is just to move the king to
support the pawn then you move your Rook
away that's what you do you move the
Rook away in that situation
so see he's moving he's just keeping his
King in
any chances at all for Nepal I can't see
any chances Ivanka has resigned and
that's it he's resigned and vidit wins
the first second tie a break game at 10
minutes plus 10